bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic les orbites dans l'univers tous les
corps possédons une masse satire entre
eux c'est ce que l'on appelle la
gravitation
ainsi si on lâche une pomme à la surface
de la terre la terre et la pomme vont
s'attirer mutuellement et la pomme va
finir par tomber au sol imaginons alors
qu'on projette un satellite vers la
droite avec une certaine vitesse à
chaque instant la vitesse du satellite
va l'entraîner vers la droite
ce qu'ils éloignent de la surface de la
terre mais comme la terre ne cesse
d'attirer le satellite vers son centre
alors celui ci va également redescendre
en direction du sol
si l'on augmente progressivement sa
vitesse le satellite va tomber toujours
de plus en plus loin jusqu'au moment où
il se déplacera assez vite pour
compenser parfaitement la gravité
notre satellite va alors d'écrire une
trajectoire circulaire autour de la
terre et rester toujours à la même
altitude
en réalité le satellite est constamment
en train de tomber sur la terre mais
grâce à sa vitesse très élevée
il s'en éloigne tout autant de sorte à
suivre la courbure terrestre
c'est ce type de trajectoire périodiques
que décrit un objet au tour d'un autre
sous l'action de la gravité que l'on
appelle une orbite
si on augmente encore davantage la
vitesse initiale du satellite alors
celui ci va se mettre à décrire des
orbites de plus en plus étirés en forme
d'ellipse sur ses orbites elliptiques la
vitesse du satellite n'est pas constante
en effet plus il est proche de la terre
plus l'attraction gravitationnelle
devient forte et donc plus il a besoin
de se déplacer rapidement pour pouvoir
compenser sa chute
enfin si on lance notre satellite avec
une vitesse encore plus élevée alors
celui-ci finirait par se déplacer
tellement vite il finirait par échapper
à l'attraction terrestre
c'est ce que l'on appelle la vitesse de
libération depuis le milieu du xxème
siècle l'homme a envoyé en orbite autour
de la terre des milliers d'objets
orbitant à basse altitude
on peut par exemple trouver le télescope
spatial hubble ou encore la station
spatiale internationale dans la station
spatiale notamment tous les objets ainsi
que les astronautes suivent exactement
la même orbite autour de la terre
en effet leur [ __ ] d'un objet ne dépend
pas de sa masse une station spatiale est
une pomme
si on les lance à la même altitude et à
la même vitesse vont décrire exactement
la même trajectoire
ainsi dans la station spatiale tous les
objets semblent flotter
car en réalité ils sont tous en train de
tomber de la même façon si on regarde
plus haut on trouve une grande quantité
de satellites comme les satellites de
géolocalisation ou encore les satellites
de télécommunications qui permettent
d'échanger des données rapidement entre
la terre et l'espace
certains de ces satellites se trouvent
notamment sur une orbite bien
particulière qu'on appelle orbite
géostationnaire
cette orbite a pour particularité d'être
exactement à la bonne altitude pour que
la vitesse du satellite suivent
parfaitement la rotation de la terre les
satellites en orbite géostationnaire
peuvent ainsi suivre la surface et de la
sorte rester toujours au dessus d'une
même région
notre monde macroscopique et
principalement régi par l'interaction
gravitationnelle
ainsi on trouve des orbites partout dans
l'univers de notre échelle jusqu'à celle
des galaxies si l'on s'éloigne de la
terre
on trouve d'abord la lune ensuite la
terre est elle même en orbite autour du
soleil
tout comme les autres planètes et
astéroïdes du système solaire si l'on
continue de s'éloigner les commettent
des crimes autour du soleil des orbites
extrêmement allongée elle reste très
éloigné de notre étoile pendant
plusieurs dizaines d'années et ne s'en
rapproche que très brièvement de façon
régulière
si l'on sort maintenant du système
solaire on peut alors trouver de
nouveaux systèmes qui sont parfois
composé de deux étoiles en orbite l'une
autour de l'autre
dans un tel système binaire les deux
étoiles ayant environ la même masse ce
n'est pas une qui va orbiter autour de
l'autre mais les deux étoiles qui vont
orbiter autour d'un centre
comment enfin si l'on s'éloigne encore
davantage le soleil ainsi que toutes les
étoiles qui forment la voie lactée
orbite ensemble autour du centre de
notre galaxie où se trouve un immense
trou noir supermassif